[Music]
while great divinity original sin - is a
tricky game that will pull no punches
when it comes to punishing your mistakes
or pushing your luck in a conversation
threat so since this may be the first
time with an original sin game for some
of you we've put together a little
beginner's guide of what you need to
know before you set off - for joy and
into the world of River lon
[Music]
if this is your first time playing I
recommend picking one of the default
classes the game gives you a great
amount of freedom in custom class
creation but it's also really easy to
mess up a create a bad skill set if you
don't know what you're doing there is a
way to reroll your character further
down a line but it will definitely make
your life tricky for the first few hours
if you want a safe bet you can roll with
an origin character and get the benefit
of playing through their story but if
not you can always recruit them later
word of warning if you want to roleplay
a skeleton it's awesome narrative Li but
makes the game tougher healing potions
and spells now hurt you and you must use
poisons regain health also friendly NPCs
are used to the idea of a walking
talking skeleton meaning you have to
wear a hood or shape-shift into a normal
form if you don't want to get attacked
or just send everyone off running to the
hills if you're ok with all that though
go ahead and pick a skeleton
seriously divinity is a challenging game
if you're on PC show that f5 key some
love and make liberal amount of quick
saves click Save before entering a new
area quick saving combat quick saving
conversations some areas are hiding
enemies that can ambush you decide who
is winning come back and shift in the
blink of an eye or the enemy him summon
reinforcements some conversations can go
sideways real fast resulting in the
person you just chatting to hauling
fireballs or your nether regions
honestly you don't want to feel the
sting of losing some hours of progress
just because your healer got teleported
into a pool of curse blood and your
party died it's not safe coming it's
playing tactically when you're starting
your character you'll get the option
taking perks these lives should depend
on what kind of character you'll be
playing but for first-timers I really
think you should take pet pal and not
just because talking to animals is cool
as hell the ability to communicate with
your beastly brethren can make your life
easier
it would allow you to avoid some tricky
areas and uncover secrets I managed to
convince a pack of dogs not to rip my
throat out just by talking to the Alpha
and rats dwelling in dungeons and sewers
have kindly warned me about traps and
ambushes before I've delved deeper into
the darkness sure it takes a perks lot
but it's worth its weight in gold and
really without it you're missing out on
some great little distractions as well
as hearing voice actors tried to get
across what a dog's speaking English
might sound like I think I love you
[Music]
when a character in your party dies the
only way to bring them back is to use a
Resurrection scroll they're quite rare
an invaluable for turning combat around
and bringing your party back to full
strength while some of the encounters in
the early game are tricky they can often
be beaten with a bit of trial and error
and some use of saves as the game goes
on though some of the battles can become
drawn-out battles with characters on
slivers of Health just holding on to
their last breaths of life this is when
you need those scrolls during the course
of a 30 to 40 minute fight your
character might go down a number of
times and in divinity original sin to
being one guy down in a fight can change
everything
also make sure that every member of your
party is carrying at least one at all
times there's no point having your main
squeeze carrying them around because if
they go down they'll take all the
scrolls with them
[Music]
it's important to stay healthy in the
world of river lon danger is around
every corner when you build your party
the members will give you the option on
how they're built I recommend taking a
healer to keep you topped up in combat
but you've got to stay perky while
exploring the world as well especially
with all the traps ambushes poison
plants fires and exploding vents that
you'll come across save your potions for
battle instead carry plenty of food
someone even have bonus status effects
if you can find a bed you can let each
party member catch 40 winks and that
will slowly refill their health bar the
best way to heal out of combat though is
to use a bed roll the ship that you
spawn on will have a few of these so
make sure to take them all as they're
not unlimited use when you use them out
in the world you will refill your
party's health back to full and gain the
rested status effect for a gross looking
sleeping bag these are super valuable
items so make sure you keep an eye out
for them when you're out in the world or
talking to traders it's important to get
your beauty sleep after all a big part
of the divinity original sin series is
your command over the elements so
experiment with spells abilities and
environments to give you an upper hand
in battle most the abilities will create
some effect or another especially if you
have a specialist spell caster like a
Pyromancer or an arrow mansur water can
be electrified oil can be set ablaze
fire can be turned to steam to block
sight steam clouds can be filled with
poison or lightning characters that are
wet and more susceptible to being frozen
or stunned characters who are decaying
will be heard by healing a lot of this
knowledge will come with experience and
a little experimentation so don't be
afraid to play around with your options
before you know it you'll be training
crazy elemental reactions and creating
cursed clouds of doomed blood that shoot
lightning
the world of divinity original sin - is
dense massive and full of awesome things
to discover so if you find that the
tricky combat is preventing you from
experience all those things then don't
be afraid to turn the difficulty down to
explore a mode the classic mode on
divinity is still a brutal way to play
but in Explorer mode the focus is much
more on well exploring getting a chance
to talk to characters and make your own
way around the world discovering things
as you go and once you feel like a
lightning spewing fire throwing
backstabbing axe wielding badass there's
nothing stopping you from going back and
dining it back up to classic mode for a
nice challenge divinity is a game that
tries to put your experience first so
feel free to experience it in just the
way you want to so those are our hints
to get you started in your adventures in
divinity original sin - if you have any
hints yourself feel free to share them
and make sure you like the video if you
enjoyed it or found it helpful next week
I'll be putting up a feature on just why
I love this gem of a game so make sure
you subscribe so you don't miss that
until then I'm going to go play under
the 20 hours the game so I'll see you
next time
[Music]